and next speaker is a vidya muthukumar
she is a phd candidate uc berkeley and a
google research fellow in the
reinforcement learning program
i was muted uh can you hear me now yeah
perfect
okay uh thanks prasad for the nice
introduction i'm a google research
fellow at the theory of rl program this
semester and i'll be joining georgia
tech as an assistant professor next year
so today i'll be talking about uh some
recent results we obtained on the
generalization error of
over primatized linear models
particularly for classification problems
and we'll actually compare these two
results that are already known for the
case of regression
so this was joint work with misha belkin
daniel sue at bien narang
we can go to the next slide
so the overall motivation here comes
from this very nice recent set of
empirical results showing
the so-called double descent curve and
the test error for regression and
classification problems
uh so for example in the over
parameterized linear model we can see
that
in the modern regime where the number of
parameters is much larger than the
number of training points
if we pick a particular kind of solution
that perfectly interpolates this data
it's doing better and better in terms of
the test error as we over primarize more
and more
and as some of you may know this is very
much it seems to be very much at all
with some of the classical statistical
learning theory which suggests that
things should only get worse as we add
more and more parameters into our model
and
what's very nice about this set of
results obtained by belkin at all
is that it recovered some of the trends
that we see
in over parameterized neural networks in
the much simpler setting of the linear
model making that
much more amenable to some nice
theoretical analysis
so we can go to the next slide thank you
so the basic setup for studying these
questions is the
over parameterized linear model um
and what that means is our output is a
function of some linear combination of d
dimensional features
so in the case of regression this is
very simple this is just the
linear model with additive say sub
gaussian noise
and in the case of classification we're
using what is called the random
classification noise model where the
label
is uh could be equal to the sign of a
linear combination of these features
with some probability
and with some non-negligible probability
the label could also be flipped
so in this high dimensional regime the
number of features is greater than the
number of samples
and we're also assuming random training
data and
the an important quantity that will pop
up again and again
is this covariance matrix or the second
moment matrix of the data
so we can go to the next slide
and in this over primary class setting
in general
we can consider the setup of linear
equations from
input to output and because the setting
is linear
uh we actually have infinitely many
interpolative solutions here that is the
we can satisfy this with equality and
we're going to be interested in
particular
in studying uh the minimum two norm
interpolation we can go to the next
slide
uh for both regression and
classification problems
and also the max margin svn for the
classification problem
so you can go to the next slide
so our main result was to analyze the
classification error both for
interpolation and
svm solutions and show that this is
actually a much easier problem than
regression
in other words there exist high
dimensional regimes in this problem for
which classification generalizes well
but regression does not
so i don't really have time to go into
the details of all of these
parameterizations but
um the main broad takeaway is that the
properties of the covariance matrix
really matter for this
problem there needs to be some effective
prioritization of some low-dimensional
features
and uh the sense in which we have a
separating regime is that for some
particular primarizations of this model
we can show that the limiting test error
for regression does not go to zero so it
stays up at something like one
but the classification error actually
goes to zero and we can go to the next
slide
so the main takeaways are as we just saw
classification
can be dramatically easier than
regression in even an asymptotic sense
for these interpolator solutions
and the key technical component here was
that we also showed that the svm and
interpolation are
exactly the same in high dimensions
suggesting that training loss functions
may not make much of a difference
um and i have just one more slide but
i'm i can zap up here uh thank you just
things on my mind are examples and
uh logistic regression thank you thanks